tonight can I just maybe make two
provocative comments which are not
they're provocative but I really believe
that they're true there's a fellow who
came to Boston about ten years ago who
was a Marxist economist from China and
he'd gotten a Fulbright scholarship and
he came to Boston to study capitalism
and democracy of all of the arcane
topics we got to know him very well
all he was was in Boston so at the end
of his time we invited him and his wife
and child to our home just to have a
goodbye dinner and I asked him so of all
the things you learned about capitalism
and democracy while you were here was
there something that was very surprising
to you that you just did never thought
about before and with no hesitation he
said yeah I never understood how
critical religion is to the functioning
of free markets and democracy and I'd
never put these things together before
but it's like this guy flies in from
Mars and this is what he sees and he
said you guys are living on cultural
momentum that's actually losing its
momentum now but if you go back a
hundred and 50 or 200 years ago almost
everybody in America on the weekend went
to a synagogue or a church and they were
taught there by people who they
respected that they should voluntarily
follow all the rules because even if the
police did not catch them God would
catch them and so you've got to be
honest
whatever you make it commitment honesty
requires that you follow through you got
to respect other people's property and
never take it from them their life and
freedom is just as valuable as yours and
he said because most Americans most of
the time have voluntarily followed the
rules democracy works even if the police
don't show up on your doorstep to beat
you up you pay your taxes
because we're conditioned and the root
cause was it was our religions that
instilled in us that ethic now he said
you just look around the world where
America has gone into a country and just
snapped its fingers and said we want
democracy right here and we want it
right now if you don't have a foundation
of a religion there and he said it's not
any religion but it's got to be a
religion that teaches those particular
rules and has enough power over people's
lives that they they instinctively
follow those rules if you try to put
free markets or and democracy into a
country that doesn't have that
foundation all you get is chaos like
Haiti for example where they don't have
that foundation we try to impose
democracy and FreeMarkets and just get a
complete breakdown of social order
it's what's happened in Russia to a
large extent so the my first concern
about our system is that if you don't
have an instinct and generally born from
a religious tradition amongst the CEOs
to voluntarily follow the rules
capitalism just doesn't work there is no
way that you can police honesty if it
doesn't come instinctively for you and
you know I thought a lot about this
conversation with that Marxist economist
and and as as so many institutions in
our society try to push religion out of
the public eye what they don't get is
these are the very institutions that
give us our civil liberties in the first
place and so it's it's a broader issue
than just ceo's but if the CEOs don't
come with that commitment to honesty
it's very hard to police it it's very
hard to instill it later on
the second thought is that the
economists have done a great disservice
to capitalism with this notion that
managers are responsible for maximizing
shareholder value it turns out God did
not reveal this to any of the prophets
of profit but rather economists in the
1800's as they were building
mathematical models of micro economic
problems the tools of economists are
calculus in calculus forces you to find
some function that you can maximize or
minimize and so they began to make
assumptions in these mathematical models
that management's responsibility is to
maximize the return to shareholders and
the use of that assumption made the
mathematics tractable and so more and
more economists began to use that
assumption they go into classrooms teach
that assumption in their models to their
students and somehow over the hundred
years or so that intervened it came to
be believed that management is
responsible for maximizing shareholder
value that even has gotten ensconced
into some laws and then another group of
economists came in with this theory
called the principal agent theory and
the idea there is that the principal's
who are the managers have a different
motivation than the Aged I'm sorry the
agents who are the managers have a
different motivation than the
principal's who own the stock and so in
order to align them their motivations we
have to have we have to give the
management a financial incentive to
maximize shareholder value and so over
the last twenty years these principal
agent economists have so influenced
boards of directors that they've given
the managers of these companies
extraordinarily attractive financial
incentives to inflate the stock prices
and so on
and I think this is syste it's a broken
paradigm in the 1960s the average
shareholder held the shares of your
company in her portfolio for six years
today 40% of the trading on the stock
exchange is done by hedge funds whose
average holding period is 60 days 55
percent of the activity on the typical
day in the stock exchange is executed by
mutual funds and pension funds whose
average holding period is 10 months so
95 percent of the volume is executed by
people who don't even hold the shares of
your company for a year do you want to
call these people shareholders they're
not there they're speculators or
investors who temporarily find
themselves owning the securities of your
company and so rather than the
management believing that they're
responsible for maximizing shareholder
value it's really time to say no you
guys temporarily find yourself in
possession of the securities of my
company and you're responsible for
maximizing the returns on your
investments and god bless you my
responsibility is to invest to ensure
the long-term health of this company the
prosperity of the employees who work
within it and the communities in which
the employees live and in which we do
our work and that really is what
management ought to focus on doing well
and if and in this business that
managers aren't incentivized anybody who
knows a manager knows that these are
driven people to achieve and to build
and to do good things and what the
economists have come in to have done to
us by giving these people financial
incentives has just really perverted the
system and so I think if we could get
rid of those assumptions that you've got
a principal agent problem
the managers are responsible for
maximizing the income of spent of
speculators if we took them out and
brought people who just had a great
grounding in in on in the value of
honesty because of their background the
CEO problems would disappear